ROMAN NURIK: Hi.
I'm Roman, and I helped design
and develop the Google I/O 2014
Android app.
In this video, I'll dive into
how we use the new material
design approach to
build a visually
striking, consistent,
and adaptive Android app
for this year's conference.
So what exactly is
material design?
At first glance, it may just
seem like a new visual design
language full of bright
colors and subtle shadows.
But it's really
much more than that.
It's a system that we
pioneered that informs
all of our visual interaction
and motion design decisions
across mobile, desktop,
wearables, and beyond.
Now every year at
Google I/O, our team
spends several whole months
working on the conference app.
We do this for two reasons.
First, it's obviously
a great companion
for the developers attending
the event and those tuning
in at home.
Second, and arguably
more importantly,
it serves as a reference
app for Android design
and development best practices.
Now, this year's app uses
material design and features
of the L developer preview to
present content in a rational,
consistent, adaptive,
and beautiful way.
Let's take a look at some of
the decisions and outcomes that
informed the app's design.
In material design,
surfaces and shadows
play an important
role in conveying
the structure of your app.
The material design
spec outlines a set
of layout principles that
help guide decisions like
where shadows should appear and
what is drawn on each surface.
For example, here's
our first iteration
of tabs in the My
Schedule screen.
It was problematic for
a number of reasons.
The single shadow
below the action bar
conveys that there are
two sheets of paper,
one for the action
bar and another
for the tabs and
schedule contents.
The problem is that the
bottom sheet is too complex.
The ink that represents
the contents of a surface
should be pretty simple.
Here, ink is doing too much
work, painting not only
text and icons but borders
and background colors.
The result is visual noise.
Our final iteration
was much stronger,
creating a clear separation
between chrome and content,
and letting the ink
focus on painting
only the important stuff--
things like text, icons,
and accent strips.
Another area where surfaces
played a role in our design
thinking was the detail screen.
In our first release,
as you scrolled,
the top banner cross-faded
between the session image
and the session color.
Our concern though
was that this design
bent the physics of
material design too far.
It's as if the text
was sliding along
a surface whose
transparency changed
throughout the animation.
A better approach, which
we introduced in an update
to the app on June 25, was
to create a shorter surface
below the image onto which
the title text was printed.
This surface had a
more stable opacity.
Before scrolling, the surface
is adjacent to the one
containing the body text,
forming what we call a scene.
And as you scroll, this surface
and the floating action button
attached to it rises
above the body text,
allowing the text to
scroll beneath it.
This aligns better
with the physics
in the world of material design.
And the end result is a more
coherent visual interaction
and motion story for our users.
Now, another key principle
of material design
is that interfaces should be
bold, graphic, and intentional,
and that the foundational
elements of print design
should guide visual treatments.
Color plays a huge role
in making that happen.
In material design, UI
color palettes generally
consist of one primary
and one accent color.
Large color fields like
the action bar background,
for example, take on the 500
shade of the primary color,
while smaller areas
like the status bar
can use a darker shade,
like the 700 value.
The accent color is used more
subtly throughout the app
to call attention
to key elements.
The resulting juxtaposition
of a tamer primary color
and a brighter accent
color gives the app
a bold, colorful look
without overwhelming
the app's actual content.
In the I/O app,
we actually chose
to use two accent colors
used in various situations.
Most accents were pink 500,
while the more conservative
light blue 500 was a better
fit for the Add to Schedule
button, which was often
adjacent to session colors.
And speaking of session colors,
we color the detail screen
based on the session topic.
For example, Android
sessions are green.
This gives the screen that
bold and intentional look.
And when choosing
our topic colors,
we used a material
design color palette
which contained dozens
of great color options.
We also needed to make sure
that each color contrasted
well enough with the floating
action button and session
images.
Here's our test graphic that
let us visualize this contrast.
Finally, we ensured
that topic colors
had a consistent brightness.
Desaturating our test file
when choosing the colors
helped in that process.
Now another foundational
element of print design
that's important in
successful material design
is layout, and
more specifically,
margins and what
we call keylines.
Now from previous
years of the I/O app,
we'd already been
accustomed to using
a 4 dp grid for sizing things.
For example, our buttons and
list items were 48 dps tall.
However, the guidance on
keylines for material design
was new to us.
After we started adhering to
the spec and, in particular,
aligning titles and other
texts to that 72 dp keyline,
we immediately felt that
clean, print-like rhythm
in our screens.
Adhering to the keyline
allowed for very fast scanning
of UI text and information
on our screens.
Gestalt principles for the win.
Now while we're on
the subject of layout,
remember that material design
applies across many device
types.
It's right there
in the principles.
A single underlying
design system
organizes interactions in space.
Each device reflects
a different view
of the same underlying system.
Now luckily, the spec
offers some great solutions
for designing across
multiple screen sizes.
For example, many of the
screens in the I/O app
represent collections
of sessions.
For these situations, the system
offers a number of containers,
like lists, grids, and cards.
Each of these can be used
across different screen sizes
to represent
collections of data.
We originally
thought to use cards
to represent session items.
It's a pretty natural choice.
But in some cases, we
wanted to conserve space
by overlaying text and images.
This simpler, more
homogeneous presentation
was less appropriate for cards.
The card shadows
in corners would
hinder the scanability
in this context.
We thought a grid would
be a better choice here.
With grids, we could vary
the number of columns
based on available screen width.
And each grid tile could take
on different aspect ratios.
The resulting presentation
was very flexible
and worked great, not
only on phones but also
7-inch and 10-inch tablets.
Finally, there is a crucial
element that ties everything
together, and that's motion.
While a big part of the motion
story of material design
is in transitions
between screens,
apps can truly
delight users when
motion is used in ways
beyond the obvious.
Let's take a look at some
of the delightful motion
we introduced in the app.
First, touch feedback ripples.
They're super, super satisfying.
They're also built in as soon
as you switch to the material
theme in L. But we
wanted to make sure
that they looked really
good on any background.
So we customized ripple
colors for many elements
to ensure the ripples were
visible but still subtle,
regardless of the background.
We also used both the
bounded and unbounded styles
where appropriate.
But my personal favorite
detail hands down in the app
is the floating button
that adds or removes
a session to your schedule.
On touch, a little ink ripple
reveals a new background color,
and the plus symbol spins and
transforms into a check mark.
Finally, while it's a bit hard
to tell in this animation,
if you press and
hold the button,
its shadow grows,
almost like the button
is lifting up to
meet your finger.
The end result is
you end up pressing
the button a few times just to
see its delightful tricks again
and again.
I do it many times a day.
So those were some of
the design decisions
we made for the I/O
2014 Android app.
Material design
influenced everything,
including surfaces, shadows,
color, layout, and motion
in the app.
Overall, the system
played a huge role
in helping us create a visually
striking, consistent, and
adaptive Android app
for the conference.
Now make sure to check
the material design spec
at google.com/design for more
on this new design approach
and how it can help
you improve your apps.
And if you're an
Android developer,
check out the code for
the I/O app on Github
to see how the design is
implemented both for Android L
and for earlier versions.
Thanks.